που εβοήθησε φαίνεται εκοίνους που το έκαμα απεφάσει σε να μιλήσει και τηλεφωνισε στονν το
προενα στυνομικό που ήταν μαζί μα στον μελί και στηκαλύναεικαι του είπε ότι νομίζω ότι
ξέω και π τους το εδώσαν ροντεύγουμε την κόρμου τη μαρία και πήαν και τους
έδειξε που τον είχαν βάλει ισχερί και η αρένα της πολιτικής είναι παιρίαρχη το ζήσατε
μεσ από δύο ισχυρούς άντρες της πολιτικής προσπαθήσατε μποέρεται κυριάπααοδοπουλού να αποτρέψε τα παιδιά σας
να σχοληθού με την πολιτική παρά το ιγονός τι σήμερα α διαφορεδική εναι τα εξει
ει εγώ δεν και τους το το έλεγα πάντα και το ξαναγίπα ότι εγώ δεν
ήμουν υππτο είναι στην πολιτική τα παιδιά μου δι ότι επιδιέζησα με δύο πολιτικούς νομίζω
ότι είναι δύσκολη ζωή δηλαδή καμνις θυσίες εν υπάρχει αφιβολία είναι και ποσυνικογένεια του προς
τα παιδιάσε εναγιασμένος να λεπεις ρκετιές ες που το σπίτι πομένο σταν κάτι που δεν
επιθυμούςγια τα παιδιά αλλά βεβαίως ο καθένας εναι ελεύθερος να διαλέξει το δρόμο του και
να κάμει αυτά που θέλει εμπορίς να επέδει στω σοεναρισμένο βαθμό λέει στην τις δυρκές
του ιδέσει σκέψεις αλλά επ εκεί και εκεί νομίζω τ πλέον τα παιδίά να ρκετάιάλέω
βλέγουν κυραβάδο πουλου τατριά ποια δεν σερα παιδιά σας είναι στην πολιτι ταδίο να πόγαναπω
ότι ταξει και αναστασία πολύ θέλουν ότι είναι μια άξα που αδικείτει κάποιες φορές λόγο
για του ονόματος ότι πολλές φορές έπρεπε να βρίσκε σε κάποιο υπουργείο αλλά ζήτούν τις
συμβουλή της κυριας ποβαδοπολου τα παιδιά τους για παράδειγμα